- [Cesar] In my family,
arepas is serious business.
If you ever came late to breakfast,
there was a really good chance
you weren't gonna have one.
Hi I'm Cesar, and today we're
making my family's arepas.
I was born in Caracas, Venezuela.
When I was 6, we left Venezuela
for the United States.
Arepas are a type of bread
that Venezuelans eat.
We eat it for breakfast,
lunch, and dinner.
The one important thing you wanna remember
is that the cornmeal has to
be poured slowly to the water
to eliminate any chance of having clumps.
At the end of the stirring,
you want to make sure
you have a very dense dough ball.
You know the arepas
dough is ready when you
press your fingers against it
and it doesn't stick to them.
The story behind my parents
is they met in college.
My father was from Venezuela,
and my mother was from Bristol, Virginia.
He was on a scholarship
and he had an opportunity
to come here and learn, but caveat to that
was that he was gonna have
to return to Venezuela
and spend some time working there.
Which meant, after my
mom and he fell in love,
she was gonna have to come with him.
She had a lot of struggles
and culture shock
when she was in Venezuela,
but one of the things
that she really could confide
in was learning how to make
traditional Venezuelan
dishes with my grandmother.
So the great thing about arepas is
you can really have them with anything.
But my favorite way that it's prepared is
my mother's chicken avocado recipe.
It's something that we call reina pepiada.
It consists of avocado, cilantro,
salt and pepper, and chicken.
You can used pulled chicken,
but if you don't have time to make that,
you can also use rotisserie style.
Arepas were always a big
part of our breakfast.
We used to have them with scrambled eggs,
ham and cheese, and butter.
One of the things that
I'm really proud about
for having two parents
from different cultures,
is the perspective I have on the world.
I get to appreciate so many things
because I've seen it from
so many different angles.
I'm really thankful to my parents
for keeping up with our
traditions from our native land.
Now I'm here at Tasty
Studios making my own video,
so I really feel like it's
the torch being passed down.
Oh, yes!
(light music)